[Music]
in class clown news look better than up
that batter with you yeah I mean you
have all the instruments I'm sure I get
the award you guys got the class code
yeah every single year I did when did
you get elementary school junior high
elementary through junior high high
school yeah I read it once in elementary
oh yeah let me just go right no junior
high do you tell you what tip funny too
funny all that's done well you had it in
elementary you were meant to be a funny
person what the hell happened you're
actually funny you got a fun at heart
you understand humor you get it but then
when a camera come on there's the button
but when a camera comes on they don't
get to see the funny Tiffany the one
that we know the ones like when people
can can read Spanish but they can't ride
it's like that kind of [ __ ] or just a
different way of interpreting the
language maybe we gotta find the tunnel
it's cuz she cares about what people say
I know I do I mean that's comedy though
you care what people say that's why you
want people to laugh yeah comedy is just
you're lashing out erratically at all
the things that you're sad about yeah
trying to be late too
anyways there it is submitted by Green
Mario that's Belize you right
no that's Mario when he somehow
superpowers or eat something new is he
bigger is he smaller there's a frog
Mario who's green oh I think that was
the cutest he's cute yeah he's a dork
yeah yeah he has a good frog you know
bounces like and I was like a 50 year
old plumber of this dressed as a frog if
you make a human it gets really great
don't do that don't do that it kind of
reminds me of Saddam Hussein you know
like Mario is Saddam who's you kind of
look the same with the mustaches [ __ ] I
think saying we need to poo never wears
pants don't do that oh yeah that's right
they're [ __ ] pervert or like any
cartoon would you like to eat out of my
honeypot Saddam was by far I think the
best dressed dictator of all time really
yeah it's not even close
I like a Dappy style oh I see you're
saying yeah well the robes and yeah
researchers say mischievous kids begin
to lose their
around age 8 and then they get them back
again in college who the [ __ ] is
researching this [ __ ] how rich are you I
know who granted the money for this [ __ ]
oh it's so funny
it was mischievous and I always had a
plethora of friends Laura
yeah a [ __ ] high myself always had a
Picasso mr. Pratt I definitely did a
point for economist what do you have a
pendulums pendulum you went back and
forth that bad cuz you had too many
they're all piece there you go yeah yeah
so researchers from the University of
Illinois at urbana-champaign discover
that the firt that first and second
graders with mischievious personalities
originally there they're one of the most
sought-after playmates when they're
first a second grade but then once they
hit third grade that's when other
classmates start to notice that the
teachers are not like they're bothered
by the class clowns and so the rest of
the classmates start to like shun the
class clown that actually feels really
true for me you telling me that
researchers found out that kids don't
want to hang out with little [ __ ]
like that's all it is it's like the kids
who think it's funny to put gum in hair
and [ __ ] eventually people don't want to
hang out with them but then it turns
back around so like I got kicked out of
school when I was six and then I went to
a private school just start second grade
and then I was trying to make friends
and then in third grade I think I got in
trouble so much I was the guy with my
own desk in the back one of the room I
started to lose friends there but then
your mischievousness starts turning to
like more like being a troublemaker and
the fourth and fifth grade those guys
start becoming friends again and not
there's a whole group of them I remember
so much detail and every part was broken
so much I don't remember like all the
kids from all they all my classes
probably 90% of them - what I remember
like places classrooms I don't remember
what grade that was I don't remember
best member like 10% but the only reason
why I remember those 10% it's because
they stuck out like a [ __ ] like a
girl named Zakia she would beat the [ __ ]
- every boy and consistently suck her
thumb every day
whoa ya know like that's a contrast
that's a hell of a contrast yeah she so
shoot just have her thumb in her mouth
and they should be stocking up boys all
over school which is amazing because we
just with one fist
I remember my fifth grade class and that
was it
before that all the classrooms all of
everything else it's just I don't
remember if that's third grade second
grade or whatever remember all of them
yeah I remember all of them all the
teachers I could plan a like 90% of the
students in I think I have to dig in
here a little bit more harder then I
don't remember I remember hardest luck
teachers mostly that's it
well actually don't remember my things
because the drugs is like sophomore
junior like senior oh that means you
could have it could've been a super
genius but you [ __ ] it all I remember
all those trips yeah I probably went
through like hundreds of raves and I
only remember maybe like three of them I
just remember elementary school teacher
and names and that's it I don't remember
any of that he's remember mrs.
Richardson because I came back because I
joined choir my senior year that's dope
and I came back and I performed it she
remembered me and then she asked me what
I'm doing I'm gonna go to college if she
said you're going to go to college yeah
[ __ ] out how the [ __ ] is happened I
don't even get to go to college how the
[ __ ] is this happening oh you know who I
saw I saw my Japanese teacher at my old
high school there was a Japanese
language teacher and I remember that
[ __ ] called my mom and said that
I need a special school I saw him at the
restaurant with just the other day and I
wanted to be like [ __ ] I've got
a million dollars and [ __ ]
employees [ __ ] but I was too scared I
wish I wish you did and he's like who
the [ __ ] are you a nurse my wife never
seen my home he's gay what does that
mean though I always had a suspicion and
he found out that are you were right
but yeah he's he's gay how did you know
he's gay was he's a [ __ ] magnet what
the dude is that color here yeah I know
I just thought I just thought like it
was like a thought in my head I was like
my teacher he's gay because he talked
like the teacher from Carta the [ __ ]
South Park oh yeah mister yeah and he
would be extra nice to some of the boys
oh no no spit the face of the young
girls I don't know he didn't like me
though didn't like me
why did you shut up but I know why he
didn't like me is because I was not good
and even though I'm Japanese I should be
able to read it right and [ __ ] like that
but I never did my homework and then
like I would do well you should still go
up to him and tell him to suck it cuz
you got a million dollars now I love
your logic I [ __ ] it up I know he
wasn't yeah didn't didn't do anything
wrong you were wrong and you still
wonder suck I know I'm good jumped him
after school the foot no I I had one of
my friends we were flirting and then
like she was sitting on my lap and we're
having conversations in the BlackBerry
class and then he was like Joseph and it
she was like just forget that [ __ ] on
your own seat and then we're laughing
because the way he was saying it was
like get out of I would see it's like
this [ __ ] it's so funny he's so mad well
crater is this this was Lady he's your
cone I would yell at you bro should go I
know I was such you're pretty no and I'm
gonna rub it in his face again when I
come hell yeah did you go to the site
you know like you were hating on me in
high school Tom told my mom I had to go
to special class and [ __ ] cuz I wouldn't
amount to nothin and I look back and I'm
like he was actually right
he helped shaped my life he made me the
man I am I know he's gonna be like
you're welcome right if I was a teacher
to and I saw a [ __ ] idiot like that
that that like hey you could speak the
language why can't you [ __ ] write the
basic alphabet yeah I think he's done to
you came full circle on your own I don't
think we needed to be here for this I
wish you were completely alone I'm not
I'm not gonna be sad anymore
I'm not gonna have resentment okay I
thought you do this in the mirror like
the Green Goblin and [ __ ] spider-man
movie you just talked yourself in the
mirror about what's going on no jakey
news help we really should go tell him
in I know he was pretty good to us if
you think about it I think well no but
you still have to remember he doubted
you okay I'm like Michael but not on
text messages ways that real time like
we can't get that back no we'll never
get it
these [ __ ] five minutes back but it
doesn't matter cuz what really matters
is I feel safe now
and I feel better and it helped me out
you thought you're in danger before and
you know what [ __ ] this in his article
right wait did you
I can't remember because he was talking
for so long but did you ever tell us
your own experiences like with your
friends and not having friends and then
you did have friends yeah just like
really briefly you weren't even
listening
I did but I felt really alone ani how do
you remember all those people in your
class dude I just remember like five or
six in elementary school high school I
remember but not elementary school I
remember I don't remember people I met
like three months ago Edwin Johnson
Garey and Johnson rub deep Sidhu what
video am i in red video whoa like if
someone brought out a picture of my
class I could probably point out every
kid and probably say all their first and
last names I remember first names I
can't remember listening I just know the
Pillman she's the only one I know both
names
I remember Greatest Hits you know I mean
it's like oh yeah a good memory
what was that [ __ ] when they would bring
a paper around with you in elementary
school and you could buy [ __ ] on it the
scholastic like book order oh yeah the
book order see it's that to this day and
then Isaac brings it home and I'm like
oh my child smell it I want weird
[ __ ] papers yeah it's all super thin
it's like the same material from the
[ __ ] wax thing when you put on a
toilet seat
yeah that's creepy we actually do it
online now and then like then you rub it
so harder than it [ __ ] gets on your
fingers
do you still get a physical book that
cracks a little bit when you open it oh
I love that with the plastic it's never
been open now that was the only thing my
parents were they come on tablet now
without me having to argue because it
was education yeah I mean so you get
like geodes or like those G old books or
whatever and that's the only way we buy
them to like get whatever you want
we would argue because they knew I
wasn't gonna read it well I just wanted
to buy cuz I want to have it oh I always
try to getting the stuff that came with
toys and that's exactly what Isaac does
today and I'm like he or so myself I was
a reading fiend though like I used to
love reading like I I used to non-stop
read all the time until I I picked up
bug guitar and I found that guitar
actually gets women to talk to you yeah
books do not know
[Music]